für mich als offs halbe dutzend hat
indirekten und direkten können und hat
sie miteinander proben die hochburg der
spd liegt in ostfriesland im
bundestagswahlkreis aurich emden hat die
partei vor vier jahren 37,8 prozent der
zweitstimmen erhalten
bei den erststimmen war es noch
deutlicher 49,6 prozent ging an den
direktkandidaten ich bin johann saathoff
bundestagskandidat für den wahlkreis
aurich emden und auch schon seit acht
jahren mitglied des bundestages dort in
der spd bundestagsfraktion
was macht ihren wahlkreis aus nun das
werden ihnen alle sagen das ist das der
schönste wahlkreis ist in der
bundesrepublik deutschland das mache ich
natürlich auch mit dem einen unterschied
dass ich auch recht und dieser wahlkreis
es hat unglaubliche potenziale aus
meiner sicht die manchmal vielleicht
nicht überall in deutschland gesehen
werden dass auch meine aufgabe in berlin
noch mal den zeiger so ein bisschen auf
den äußersten nordwesten der
bundesrepublik zu lenken
wir haben unmengen erneuerbare energien
und ich bin ganz sicher dass
wirtschaftspolitisch den regionen mit
erneuerbaren energien auch die zukunft
gehört gleichzeitig das ist ein schöner
wahlkreis hier kommen viele menschen her
der tourismus ist ein wichtiger
standbein und wir produzieren die besten
autos die es auf der welt zu kriegen
gibt mit frei in ostfriesischen arbeiter
händen
also ist eine gute kombination die wir
in diesem wahlkreis haben was sind die
größten herausforderungen in der region
es gibt schon seit jahrzehnten probleme
mit strukturwandel im bereich der
werftenindustrie zum beispiel im bereich
der landwirtschaft gibt es ganz starken
strukturwandel schon über jahrzehnte und
ein stück weit ist unser problem dass
wir eben ziemlich am rand deutschlands
zwar mitten in europa aber am rand
deutschlands liegen und da die
politische aufmerksamkeit das eine oder
andere mal noch mal eingefordert werden
muss wie ticken die leute hier
die menschen sind ein besonderer schlag
wir haben unsere eigene sprache auf die
wir auch stolz sind ich selber auch
stolz bin und freue mich auch ostfriese
sein zu können und tank hier auch wieder
auf also wenn so eine sitzungswoche war
ich komme gerade aus der sitzungswoche
in berlin dann ist es eigentlich eine
gute gelegenheit hier auch wieder kraft
und energie zu tanken sie sind sehr sehr
verbunden mit ihrer region
aber sie sind auch sehr offen und
ehrlich authentisch miteinander
hier gibt es eine direkte ansprache die
mag dem einen oder anderen vielleicht
nicht gefallen aber ich finde es
angenehm mit menschen zu tun zu haben
die nicht hintenrum denken sondern
direkt sagen was sie meinen
was ist ihr erfolgsrezept
ich glaube dass einfach erklärt mein
erfolgsrezept ist dass wahlkampf nicht
drei wochen vor der wahl anfängt sondern
am tag nach der wahl
und dass man aus der mitte der
gesellschaft kommen muss und ansprechbar
sein muss man darf nicht abheben sondern
man muss mit den menschen
gemeinsamkeiten haben viele dinge hobbys
auch auch berufliche gemeinsamkeiten ich
versuche viele praktika zu machen
ich sage hey post friesland hat meine
handynummer bin ansprechbar rund um die
uhr
das gibt mir kraft aber es auch ein
stückweit erfolgsrezept wie stehen die
chancen für die spd bei der
bundestagswahl
was mir hoffnung macht ist dass wir auch
den richtigen kanzlerkandidaten haben
schon seit monaten lange zeit vorher
haben wir das was was die union eine so
vorgeführt hat ist ja das was sonst
immer uns zugesprochen wurde dass wir
darüber kracher das hatten wir nicht
und in den umfragen sind die werte von
olaf scholz einfach sehr gut und ich
glaube dass unmittelbar vor der wahl
menschen sich auch noch mal fragen
müssen welche partei steht eigentlich
dafür das was mir wichtig ist und
deswegen habe ich noch guter hoffnung
dass wir im endspurt auch noch zulegen
werden was wünschen sie sich für die
bundestagswahl jeder der kandidiert
wünscht sich natürlich dass er die wahl
gewinnt das gilt genauso auch für mich
ich wünsche mir dass die spd die werte
auch erlangt die sie eigentlich verdient
hat aus meiner sicht in die liegen
deutlich höher als die die wir jetzt
gerade in umfragen sehen dass die
menschen erkennen dass der progressive
teil der regierung und der der diese der
deutschland durch die krise geführt hat
der sozialdemokratische teil ist und
dass auch wertschätzen und deswegen
wünsche ich mir dass das spd
wahlergebnissen gutes sein wird und tue
jedenfalls alles dafür was ich jetzt in
den nächsten wochen und monaten noch
machen kann